- [Interviewer] All right, Asha.
- Hi.
- [Interviewer] Asha, where
are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- [Asha] Where did I
grow up? Silver Lake, LA.
- [Interviewer] LA?
- [Asha] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your family.
- [Asha] My father is
Peruvian and my mom's Korean.
I was raised from my paternal
side by my grandmother,
a long line of alcoholic.
I don't know so much about drug addicts
but big time alcoholics.
- [Interviewer] Is that why your parents
were out of the picture?
- No, my parents were out of the picture
because my mom wanted a
green card, not a daughter.
She got stuck with a daughter
who she quickly abandoned
'cause she used to get
the shit beat out of her.
So she left me with my dad who decided
that he would give me to his mom
and she raised me until I was 13.
And then she decided
that she had done her job
and it's time for me to come
back to live with my dad.
So I lasted 12 months and I moved out.
- [Interviewer] And you
moved out of what age?
- 14.
- [Interviewer] 14.
- And so-
- [Interviewer] How
was life with your dad?
- Hard, you know, he
grew up very old school.
The woman cooks, cleans,
does everything for the man.
In this case, even though
I wasn't like a wife
I was still his daughter,
and his form of correcting
you was very violent.
He would, you know, punch me,
he loved to punch me.
And his favorite was like
throwing chairs at me.
So it wasn't exactly like
the greatest atmosphere.
Like I said, I put up with it full time
12 months and I moved out.
I was able to get a job with the city
painting murals in Silver
Lake, for the summer.
So earning my 4.15 an hour,
I was very proud and said,
"You know what? I don't
need to put up with your.
I'm outta here."
I never went home.
I had, you know,
crazy year being 14 and
ended up pregnant at 15.
Had my daughter at 16, pregnant at 16,
had my son at 17,
by then I was very, very
addicted to crack cocaine.
Was fortunate I didn't
use while I was pregnant,
but soon after my son was born,
I fell right back into it.
'Cause that's how I
survived, I sold crack,
I mean, that's what I knew how to do.
And endless supply, so it was easy for me
to just fall into it.
Long story short, when my
son was about, I don't know,
year and a half, he wanted me to carry him
and I pushed him away 'cause
I needed to go take a hit.
And that was my bottom.
I got sober and was sober
for 10 years, raised my kids.
They are great amazing
people, not like me,
but you know how shit happens.
Life goes on, right?
So we moved to Georgia
so I could give them
the lifestyle that they deserved.
And I met my current husband there.
He'd like, I'd mentioned outside,
he was in the military for eight years,
four of which I was with him.
We went through one deployment
together to Afghanistan,
and he came back a very different person.
And I turned back into what I guess
I tried to get away from.
And unfortunately I ended up
in jail for aggravated assault,
met the wrong girl and tried heroin.
Brought it home and just,
it was an endless insatiable like
stomach tiffy, you know.
I didn't know what kind
of addicts my husband was.
I knew what kind of addict I was.
And if it's in my face, I
can't say no, I have to do it.
So he'd make sure that
there was just enough
for me to fuck up that day
so I couldn't bitch at him.
Woke up sick one day,
a couple of years later
we lost everything.
So after 20 years of not selling dope
I went right back to selling it.
And I kept us off the
streets for about a year.
We stayed in hotels and I
caught charges eventually.
Ended up finding a rehab for couples
which is really unheard
of, we lasted a week.
We got kicked out because
of our anger issues.
And the idea was since
he receives a pension
we'd go to Mexico and live
comfortably if anything,
and still be able to get high of course.
But when we got here, we
needed about two weeks
till he got his paycheck
for us to cross into Mexico.
While we were here, our IDs
and his bank card got stolen.
So we got sucked into downtown.
It's been very wild, you know.
Good example, I recently had
to like leave the downtown area
and go to MacArthur because
some of the black sets
some of the males had pretty
much kept their eye on me
'cause I'm loyal to my husband.
And I know how to make money by hustling,
selling whatever, not myself.
So they took, how do I put this?
Basically they had a meeting so to speak,
and said, "These are the
males from these sets."
That they were interested in making me
a new boss or a boss bitch.
And I guess it's what it's called.
And so I had a choice, I
could become what they wanted
and my husband could
come along for the ride
and not be hurt, or
they would just take me
and put me in a tent
and do what they wanted.
And my husband would get fucked off.
So we went to MacArthur
where there's my race
and looked for, I guess, sanctuary there.
It's worked out so far, but
it's never a dull moment, ever.
(laughs) There's so many compromises
that you have to make out here.
- [Interviewer] Where are you living now?
- Across the street from
(indistinct) (laughs) on Alvarado
- [Interviewer] At MacArthur Park?
- Yeah, in MacArthur Park.
- [Interviewer] Did a tent?
- Yeah, in a tent, so.
- [Interviewer] With your husband though?
- Yes, with my husband.
That part's not so bad, believe it or not.
It's everything that goes on
around it, that's kinda bad.
Although I do miss running
water (laughs), so.
- [Interviewer] How does
MacArthur Park compare Skid Row?
- (sighs) It's the same,
but it's very different.
I mean, it's the same, you know you have-
- [Interviewer] That is rundown and is-
- You know, downtown, isn't
what it used to be though.
They had all these facelifts,
and but Skid Row is still Skid Row,
and it's still, you know-
- [Interviewer] Downtown has improved,
but Skid Row is still-
- It's still Skid Row.
- It is, and it probably always will be
until they decide to move the
entire homeless population
to a whole other area, which you know,
with everything that's happening
right now could happen.
I think part of it is, you know,
you come up seeing something
and it's all you know,
so why fix it if it's not broken?
'Cause nobody realizes just
how broken we all are out here.
We don't realize, or maybe we do
and we choose not to see it.
So we get high or we
go do whatever mission
just to take our mind off
of what's really going on.
And it gets old, but it's, you know,
today's adventure (laughs).
We're all a bunch of
big kids out here, man.
I mean, I know I am.
I like step back and
see some of the things
that like we do, and try to look at it
from an outsider's point of view,
and it's like, "Man, I'm 14 again,
I'm going on this little convoy
to find a place to go get high
where the cops won't find us."
Where this used to be pot now-
- [Interviewer] It's adults
living with no responsibility.
- Right.
And there's such an allure to that,
but believe it or not there's
so many more rules out here.
I mean, the real world doesn't
have shit on us out here
'cause you have to make
sure that you don't
say the wrong thing or look the wrong way.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, it's
a different set of rules.
Very different but-
- That don't make sense all the time.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- It's kind of like math laws.
It's just always has been.
- [Interviewer] And it
changes block by block.
- True.
But it's just the way it's always been.
So it always will be, you know,
there's again, why fix it?
And it allows those that
are strong to survive
and those that aren't to not.
- [Interviewer] Do you
prefer this lifestyle
to one where you have a
job, and you pay bills,
and you have responsibilities?
- I don't know that I prefer it.
I'm comfortable, it's familiar to me.
It's what I grew up knowing.
Growing up with my grandmother, I mean,
you know, as an adult you
look back at your childhood
and whatnot and you
know in a way it's like,
"How can I not be what I am today?
Which is how can I not hustle?"
I remember my grandmother sewing
money into my great-grandfather's suit
to go to Peru, back home to Peru,
you know, shit like that.
And you think back and you're
like, "Well, wait a minute,"
as an adult, "That's
not very legal" (laughs)
"Weren't they supposed to report that?"
So it's just sometimes
things that we go through
lead us to a point in
life that we have no idea
what or where we're going.
I'm just trying to keep
my head above water,
and it gets hard, it gets
old, but it's what I do.
- [Interviewer] Do you
feel like you're following
in someone's footsteps?
- Not really.
I mean, as far as like the
normal, well not normal,
but the average stereotype
of a female out here,
not even really that.
- [Interviewer] But you
don't see any behaviors
in your parents that you're kind of-
- I mean, I'm kind of amoral,
like things that should not
be okay with me are, you know.
It's like, I don't really look down on
maybe not paying your taxes
on time, things like that.
You know, things like
that are kind of trivial,
but it's just relative.
It's just a different level,
I guess, than out here.
It's like, it's you know,
it's okay to I guess
maybe screw on paying
the bill at the store.
So we go in, some of us will
shoplift or what have you,
and we know it's wrong, I know it's wrong
but I'll take the merchandise
if I need it, you know.
It's whatever I have to do to survive.
- [Interviewer] Is the
cutting on your left arm
from long ago or from recent?
- No, I'm still a cutter.
- [Interviewer] You're still a cutter?
- Yeah, I've done quite well
I'd say in the last year
I've only cut maybe once or twice,
and it wasn't very deep,
but I started when I was 14
just like any other addiction
it had to get worse,
more stitches, deeper,
just to fix the same-
- [Interviewer] Have you
ever thought you were
truly suicidal or is it just
like a call for attention?
- No, I mean, I've woken
up on life support before.
So, that sounds so dramatic,
you know on a ventilator (indistinct).
So that's also another reason why we,
we being me and my kids moved
to Georgia about 14 years ago.
I'd had a really bad
episode, never really dealt
with my depression and went on,
I guess, I don't know.
I guess from what I was told
I started on a Friday
and woke up on a Monday.
It's a machine breathing for me,
and I'd had been really,
really just upset and depressed
overall about life.
My great aunt, she was
the eldest of our elders
on my dad's side, had basically
turned her back on me.
And she's the only person I had had
who loved me unconditionally.
Unfortunately she's mentally ill
and it was my obligation
to have her committed
for the first time in her life.
So she stopped interacting with me
and I couldn't take it (laughs).
So apparently I ODed
on a whole bunch of crap
pills and booze and whatnot.
But as far as the cutting's concerned,
you know it's in designs 'cause
I don't want my kids growing up knowing
that their mom was not okay.
So I could lie to them and tell them,
"Well, it's just a tattoo without ink."
'Cause you know, kids
are supposed to be kids.
They're not supposed to worry
that their mom's not all right today.
And I mean, it worked until it didn't.
And when it didn't, it
was really, really bad.
I got drunk,
and ended up getting like
over a hundred stitches that night.
Unfortunately in the process of cutting,
I woke up my kids and they saw me being
pretty much carried out to my
car in a big old bloody mess.
And they'd never seen
that, they didn't know.
So I think that was a lot worse
than maybe as they were getting older,
sitting them down being like,
"Hey, this is what's really going on."
But I didn't, I don't know.
I had an idea of what a good
parent was supposed to be
'cause I learned everything
to not do (laughs)
from my parents.
And sometimes it works
and sometimes it doesn't.
Any other questions?
- [Interviewer] No, it's good.
Asha, thank you so much
for talking with me and-
- No problem.
- [Interviewer] Good luck and hope you
and your husband figure this out.
- Oh we will, we've been
here over a year, so.
- [Interviewer] Excellent, thank you.
- [Asha] Cool, thank you.